[Music]
Amy you've been out for two years and
you've never kissed a girl I really
don't know what I'm doing with all that
stuff I was secret for you
yeah like I wish that would have been a
secret but you've mentioned it many many
times she's got a really cute smile go
talk to her it's the last day we got you
through high school I need to go into
their budget numbers
can't we just graduate head off to
college that's do it right persist I
can't hear you
I can't soundproof glass it'll party to
me what nobody knows that we are fun we
didn't party because we wanted to focus
on school and get into good colleges and
it works with the irresponsible people
who partied also got into those colleges
I'm incredible at hand jobs but I also
got a 1560 on the SATs I've done
anything we haven't broken any rules
name one person whose life was so much
better because they broke a couple of
rules Casa he broke our rules Rosa Parks
naman else was in the anthony god damn
it
put your lips hand sanitizer chapstick
check mace listen it is very important
that you keep the safe
what is this oh my god
[Music]
well it seems excessive shotgun just
kidding I don't have one don't see we're
having a date night why it's funny your
parents think we're boning but you two
have is special we are going to show
each other how much we care about each
other well probably just do a Korean
face mask I don't need to know all the
words
[Music]